the University of South Carolina is
mourning the death of a student who was
killed after she mistakenly got into a
car she thought was an uber samantha
Josephson was last seen friday after a
night out with her friends police have
now charged a 24 year-old suspect with
Joseph's ins murder and kidnapping last
night hundreds of students held a vigil
to pay their respects
David beg know is following this
investigation David good morning this is
such a frightening story for so many
people or we can all imagine our so
we've all gotten wrong over at one point
or another not only did this woman this
woman get into the wrong car police say
she could not get out because the
suspect had the child lock on Samantha
Josephson was at a bar last Friday with
her friends at around 1:30 a.m. when
they lost track of her within 36 hours
hunters found her body she truly was
those who knew 21 year old college
seniors Samantha Josephson remember her
as having an infectious smile and a
contagious laugh she had a personality
and a presence that lit up a room
every time she entered this image shows
the last time she was seen alive after
separating from her roommates
she mistakenly got into this black Chevy
Impala she thought he was her uber
police say once she got into that
vehicle she could not get out the child
safety locks were activated on the door
that would not allow someone to the
means of escape at about 1:30 Friday
afternoon
Joseph's ins friends reported her
missing later that day turkey hunters
discovered her body more than 65 miles
away in this secluded wooded area early
Saturday morning officers pulled over
the suspect Nathaniel David Rolland he
was driving the Impala the police had
been looking for he fled on foot before
officers caught him further examination
determined that there was what appeared
to be blood present in the car officers
also found window cleaner bleach and a
victim's cell phone yesterday in court
Joseph's ins mother pleaded with the
judge to put Roland away for the rest of
his life
[Music]
so we just got this information from a
source Boober has no record of any
driver matching the suspects name
anytime you use uber remember this the
app will always show you a picture of
the driver tell you his or her name and
give you a license plate of the vehicle
that you're supposed to get into it so
feel Samantha's mom mm-hmm you don't
understand how somebody could do that to
another human being I'm just glad they
caught him thank you David
thank you very much